foreign
welcome back to another episode of the
best of the Ramsay show I'm George camel
co-host of the show and here's the deal
everybody's talking about real estate
right now and we hear it all on the show
we're going to dive into saving for a
house checking your insurance coverage
renting versus buying how much house you
can actually afford and more check it
out let's start with Maria this hour in
Chicago hi Maria welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hi Dave very excited to talk to you
thank you so much sure um my question my
question is this it's going to be uh
well I guess I'll ask the question first
and then I'll give you the background
okay is it Financial is it finally just
financially speaking not not regarding
how I feel about home ownership just
financially speaking I'm 58 years old
I I I have no debt I have fully funded
emergency funds I have fully funded
retirement both Roth and 40K how much I
own my how much is in it there's about a
million in it okay
um good for you well done between the
between the both I raise my four kids
they're all out of college
um I'm single and I my home's worth
about 350 and I paid it off it's paid
off okay taxes are really high taxes are
really high in Illinois
okay but anyway so I I think I want to
downsize because I don't need my house
anymore cool and I'm not I I I so I
would go to like a townhouse okay so
just financially just financially
speaking it wouldn't be a really bad
idea for the next 30 years for me just
to rent and the reason why I asked that
it's because in my heart I've had so
much responsibility in my whole life
raising my four kids keeping up with my
house I wouldn't mind just writing a
check every month and just be done and
uh funny but everybody's telling me like
financially speaking you could sell your
house to 350. go buy something for 250
or less I'm like but then I thought you
know then I gotta worry about the house
again the windows the roofs the gutters
the all that you know
[Music]
no yeah it makes a lot of sense I
understand so uh did you raise your kids
by yourself or your single mom
for the most part I mean I was divorced
and they were very very young he was he
was so for 20 years for 20 years you've
been a she bear out here fighting
scratching clawing and you've cleaned
the gutters you've done whatever it took
and you're just tired
yes I look over time every month at work
that I made sure I was yeah I thought
you were there at the house in time I
thought you were that girl you sound
like that girl you sound like a warrior
a Warrior Princess
um
so uh
well let's first answer your question
then let's try to look for a solution
okay the problem with your the good part
about your theory is you don't have to
screw with stuff because the landlord
does so you get all this stuff out of
your life the bad part about this is
think about what rents have done in the
last 30 years
you think and think about what they're
going to do during the 30 years that
we're talking so if you rent instead of
owning a paid for property going into
retirement you're destabilizing your
life because every year your housing
cost is going to go up
sure
so that's why it's a bad plan
it's not a bad plan to rent for a short
period of time while you're rearranging
things or you're in a transitionary
stage or something like that but renting
for 30 years means you are a victim of
the real estate market instead of riding
the wave
can I throw something else at you yep
okay so I put down on paper because this
has been like uh stressing me out so I
put down on paper my taxes versus all my
bills in my house I think you need to
move
okay but like I I even projected cost if
I was in a townhouse yeah here's what uh
here's what I want you to do here's what
I would do if you're my little sister
and you're old enough to be my little
sister okay oh I'm not not your older
sister no I'm 60. so I got you beat but
the uh uh but so uh I would tell you you
don't want to work on crap and you don't
want crap breaking and you are a
millionaire
so you need to go and buy a brand new
condominium where someone does all the
exterior maintenance and every Appliance
and everything inside is brand freaking
new you earned it you're a rock star and
you need to enjoy a little bit of this
money and it's like buying a really nice
car that's in really good shape after
you've been driving a freaking beater
and it breaks down all the time and you
know my cars don't break down now
back when I had crap cars because I was
trying to get here they broke down all
the time but you're a warrior girl and
you need to you need to enjoy The Spoils
of the battles that you have won and
that's a million dollars and a 350 000
paid for house you're worth a million
and a half dollars I want you to sell
this house I want you to buy 350 000
condo you may want to move uh to an area
that is that probably might feel a
little bit oh like it's a little too
Richie Rich for you but you need to live
there anyway
wow okay I'll think about this thank you
very good information what do you think
John yeah I think that transition when
you it's when you're a single mom when
you're raising kids and you're putting
them through college and you're saving
you're working you're doing overtime
it's kind of like being gazelle intense
for 20 30 years and suddenly you're uh
your identity is I'm a sprinter I'm a
fighter that's what I do yeah and how do
you settle back down you could hear like
man for someone who's accomplished but
she's accomplished the fact that this
decision is keeping her up means it's
not about this decision it's about I've
got to shift gears and become something
else right that's a big big transition
yeah what do you do when you come home
from a 20-year campaign
on the road with Alexander the Great and
you're one of his soldiers after 20
years how do you stop
fighting and scratching you will pick
your neighbors
you know and so you know and that's what
she issues a warrior princess that's
right and so you know she's been these
single moms man they get her done these
are some of the toughest people in on
our planet and
um so yeah that that's uh
and that's who she is and and she's like
I I you know she's kind of telling
herself good things like I deserve a
rest that's right and and Dave we talk a
lot about people making decisions out of
stress or out of
um anxiousness
that's very similar to making decisions
out of exhaustion I'm just I'm done I'm
out right I just wanna I know the math
is bad I know it's going to destabilize
me 20 years from now I'm exhausted I
don't want to fix anything else I want
to talk to any more freaking repairmen
I've talked to people who get divorced
because I'm just tired of it right so I
love your I love your idea of man right
now it feels good it's not going to be
good down the road no it's a bad
long-term plan
Debbie is with us in Detroit hi Debbie
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up
my husband and I made a huge mistake
we moved into a houseboat uh two months
ago and with the housing market being so
crazy and lots of competition for homes
we made a mistake of buying a house for
more than we wanted to spend
um we paid over list and Appraisal
and we're now in a house that um
we just feel like we can't afford the
mortgage payment it also has a pool that
is much more of an expense than we
thought it would be the house needs a
lot of repairs and some things have come
up in the last couple of months that we
didn't realize we're going to need to be
repaired right away
um so my question is
should we
plan on selling it
or stay for at least two years
um and then not have to worry about
capital gains
but if we sell it now we would probably
walk away with you know losing about 40
Grand
there is no capital gain when you lose
money
right but on the odd chance that we were
if you broke even if you break even
there's no Capital yeah
capital gain would only occur if you
made a profit
right
so it doesn't sound like that's a
problem
yeah
but if if we sold it for what we bought
it if we just broke even we'd probably
lose about 40 Grand
with closing costs and everything
so what's your house payment
um well that's the other thing too it's
more than what we thought it would be
with the property taxes are going to be
more than we had planned for so with
property taxes and insurance it's about
2 300 a month and what's your monthly
take-home pay in your household
about nine thousand okay
right
well you're slightly above what we would
tell you but not a huge amount
um it doesn't sound like this your house
payment's not 40 of your take-home pay
um
this sounds more emotional than
mathematical
okay
we just we feel like we've been bleeding
money ever since we moved into the house
because of the pool and the repairs that
have been needed and what have you spent
on repairs
I'm sorry what have you spent on repairs
cool it's been
uh over a thousand dollars
um with the repair we just had a garage
door repair that was over 700. you need
uh would you pay for the house
um we paid 410 for it
and you had
fifteen hundred dollars worth of repairs
and you're panicking
yeah you make 100 you make 140 000 a
year
Yeah well yeah yeah this is emotional it
doesn't sound like you're bleeding out
it feels like you got a little scrape on
the knee but it's just a lot it sounds
like it's more stress of just we're
having a I think you're super impulsive
and you did something that you wished
you hadn't done and that's what's
killing you the Math's not killing you
okay
I mean we should it's not ideal
yeah but um I I probably would just
breathe a little bit here
um okay you know I I
okay here's the thing the house
payment's not out of control the repairs
are not 28 000 in one month there were
fourteen hundred in one month
and you make a hundred and forty there's
nothing here that's causing red Sirens
to go off and fireworks and panic in the
numbers okay now I understand you have a
deep sense of regret because you feel
like you impulsed and overpaid uh but so
I don't want to trade a fourteen hundred
dollar repair and a house payment is
slightly over the margins we teach which
are conservative for a forty thousand
dollar loss right
well the other thing that I'm worried
about too is
um we moved with our jobs because now we
can do our jobs from anywhere after
covid and there is a chance that my
salary could be decreased based on where
we're living now well if that happens
and you can't afford the house we can
talk about selling it then but we don't
sell a house on what might happen the
house might get hit by a tornado too
yeah
but we're not going to sell it because
it might
right Debbie do you guys have any other
debt other than this mortgage
we do have a car payment
um we owe about 12 Grand on a car we
only have one car and then we um just
from the move we've got about six
thousand on credit cards so it sounds
like there's some other pieces to this
puzzle that are causing this stress do
you have an emergency fund
um we have about 25 000 in savings right
now I would write a check and pay off
the credit card and cut it up and pay
off the car today
right okay and you guys need to get on a
budget you are not in control with your
spending
the Beale is with us Nabil is in Atlanta
hi Nabil how are you
hi Dave thank you for having me on the
show sure what's up
so I'm a 23 year old with about 80 000
85 000 saved I've got about 25k in my
Roth IRA and 401k and about 60k in
investments in index funds which with
I'm looking to purchase my first home
wow where'd you get all that
so I work at a job I've just been
following your principal since I
graduated college and I've kind of every
stimulus every uh piece of extra money
that I've gotten I've kind of just put
away and tried to save so not count your
Roth you got like 145 000 bucks
no no so it's a total of about 85 it's
about 60 in the oh the whole game is
that okay yes okay got it um so
basically I make about 120 000 uh at a
job that I really relocated to about six
months ago and because I'm already
traveling I just moved back in with my
parents uh so I'm looking to buy a home
with which I would use as both a primary
residence and also simultaneously rent
part of it out to make up for the costs
of me not being there because of my work
travel what are you doing now good so
essentially I'm a project manager
setting up new warehouses across the
country
and you're killing it good job dude
you're killed thank you do you like the
job you like traveling
yeah I do I do I'm only uh it kind of
complicates the housing because I'm only
in my home City for about four days a
month I'm kind of just on the go into
hotels uh so that's why I'm trying to
see whether now it's kind of a good time
for me to buy a townhouse or a small
house in the 250 to 300 000 range I
would for this purpose and how do I kind
of find it I wouldn't either I wouldn't
I wouldn't neither you're not there
enough to manage it
the whole thing will melt before you get
back
Okay so
I recommend that someone like myself uh
in the coming years say I were to stay
in the shop how would you recommend I
pursue home ownership I would later but
right now I think you're being very wise
to listen here's the thing
I owning a home uh crap breaks
whether you're there or not
and it's just it adds you have a very
simple very clean very efficient life
and I would let someone else manage the
domicile
rather than you having a let's say you
had a roommate that decided they want to
sell all your furniture on Ebay while
you were gone
that could happen
it's happened before
um and so you get back the roommates
gone all your stuff's gone and you file
a police report but uh well yeah I mean
I've got a relatively new house and I
just got a report last week I got to
replace an air conditioner the whole
unit the whole thing yeah I don't know
why you want to do all that right now I
I think there's plenty of time as young
as you are to own a piece of real estate
I would wait at least 12 months maybe 24
months and if you're home four days
a month rent the Ritz
yeah I didn't think about that go to the
nicest hotel in Atlanta the Rich
Buckhead it's a nice property I've
stayed there and just just for four
nights
your life will be so much better people
will like bring food to your door and
stuff and they'll even come in your room
and set it up and you don't have to go
buy food they'll wash your towels it's
called room service and you don't have
to change the beds I mean it's in a mess
that's what I would do and just have a
really nice efficient life and let my
energy be spent my spiritual emotional
physical energy be spent on something
other than home ownership for four days
a month
okay that makes a lot of sense thank you
but I'm okay now long term I do want you
to buy so let's let's set a goal 25
years old you buy
because I think your life will change I
don't think you want to do this
indefinitely
this Gypsy thing yes that makes sense
yeah it's going to be I mean that like
this is not conducive to family life
right
no definitely not it's it's very much
you're living like a nomadic life yeah
yeah and it's kind of cool you're
getting to see a lot of stuff you're a
young guy it's kind of a you know little
uh uh yeah like you said nomadic that's
all cool all that's kind of fun I would
do it I definitely do it if I was your
agent single I think all day long you
get to see a lot of cities and America's
got some wonderful cities you get to see
some cities that aren't wonderful that
are out there too if you do this for two
years you're gonna blink you could have
250 000 in cash yeah just sitting there
just keep piling up some money and then
just go buy you a house but not for four
days a month no I wouldn't I like real
estate but it is not it is
the UN the thing that nobody talks about
with rental real estate or personal
residence is either one is they break
and you have to have people come over
and fix crap you know and or fix it
yourself with your little YouTube video
or whatever it is you're doing but oh my
gosh and on and and there's
entire portions of my life have been
used up on broken stuff around real
estate you know that you don't have to
have if on the short term if you're in
his situation so I I liked having my all
my life back my bandwidth back to do
like fun stuff or whatever or the four
days you're home just relax yeah and
just have no houses and peace no hassle
no hassle no hassle no hassle that's fun
that's fun it's fun to have no house
Nathan's with us in Pensacola hi Nathan
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave uh long time listener I
appreciate your show and uh definitely
live by almost all the advice you have
well thank you how can I help
um
so
um my wife and I
um are looking at possibly buying a
property it's a little bit more
expensive than what I'm used to buying
so um right now we own a home and uh
we're just trying to figure out if it
makes sense to take our our current
Investments and just basically liquidate
our current Investments and then now uh
go into debt with a mortgage that would
be probably about a 300 000 mortgage
after we're done with liquidating all of
our expenses all of our debt I'm sorry
all of our uh assets
okay how old are you
uh we're 47 47 and 46. all of your
assets you mean you're pulling
retirement out
no no no
um the retirement I can't touch until uh
later but we've got um uh listening to
you guys on like uh smart investor kind
of stuff and uh we went with uh a smart
investor Pro here in Pennsylvania
how much money and Investments that are
non-retirement
um probably about uh 600k total okay
and your current residence has how much
equity in it
about 400 okay so you're buying a
million three house
it's going to be a little bit less than
three but it'll be a little over a
million
okay I missed how you get 300 000 in
debt because I got a million dollars
here 600 and 400.
so I guess uh if the mortgage might not
be quite 300
um it'll be probably closer to 200. when
we uh when you have all the closing
costs and everything into it
okay so you're talking about you're not
going to net 400 out of your house
oh we should we should net 400 out of
the house and you have 600 in
Investments
and savings and everything yes that's a
million and the house is a million
there's not two hundred thousand dollars
in closing costs there's not a 20
closing cost there's no such thing
so I guess it's just kind of an uneasy
feeling going with a higher home value
and just I guess the biggest that I have
is it doesn't make sense to liquidate
the uh the Investments that we have
right now I wouldn't buy the house if I
didn't
because you're going to go into debt so
it's the same question of if I had a
paid four million dollar house would I
go borrow 600 000 on it to put money
into Investments no I wouldn't not
taking the money out of the Investments
and putting them on the house is the
same thing as borrowing on your house to
do that so you should not buy the house
unless you're willing to use the
Investments to do it what's your
household income
uh right now it's probably about 110.
and how old are you guys
48 room 46.
will you be able to afford the taxes on
a million dollar property at a with a
hundred thousand dollars a year just to
just to maintain the property keep the
lights on this thing keep the yard mode
uh yes we will
yeah um Florida's got some generous uh
disabled veterans uh tax benefits okay
so why why do you want to buy a million
dollar property
it's it's something my wife and I have
always dreamed about living on water and
this is an opportunity to do so right
now
okay I don't think you're gonna need a
mortgage or if you do it's a very very
small one and you're going to turn
around and get that paid off as fast as
you can if you're sitting in this
property debt free
uh within a couple of years then I'm
fine with this idea if you want to do it
um it the the thing that's out of
balance that you're feeling is is that
the vast majority of your net worth is
now tied up in your single family home
that does not that does not generate an
income
it does grow in value but it does not
generate an income and so
um you know you're gonna have to really
pour on the coals and build some
Investments by the fact that you don't
have any house payment in the near
future uh to make this work but no you
don't need a 300 000 mortgage the
numbers you keep giving me that you act
like they add up and they don't add up
I mean 600 and 400 is 1 million and you
buy a million dollar house for a million
dollars and you use a million dollars
you shouldn't have a mortgage
uh and so awesome but this makes me
uncomfortable like it makes me uneasy
that's a lot of the reason is is that
all everything you own is going into
this house except your retirement and uh
it is it's out of balance it's too much
really uh but if you're paying cash for
it I think you can tolerate it as long
as you turn around and start dumping
money into retirement really really
quick uh would I do this if I were in
your shoes no I wouldn't yeah no I
wouldn't maybe that's what I wouldn't
either because I don't want that much of
my net worth
making a hundred and ten thousand
dollars tied up in a single family house
that does not create income and I'm
thinking of it if the air conditioner
goes out on this million dollar house
it's going to be an expensive repair or
if the driveway needs to be or if I got
to do some Plumbing work on them it's
all so expensive everything let me just
100 of the houses break yeah yeah 100 of
them need crap done to them and um brand
new no matter who built them no matter
where they are
I mean I'm a lot of real estate and
there's just uh they they eat money yeah
so you're put to your point that's good
yeah I think I I you know the more I
share and talk this through listening to
John too I'm risk averse though so let
me say that a lot but I mean I
there's just no margin here there's no
there's no way I can't come back to
margins there's no wiggle room what if
you get sick I wonder if you get
something life goes sideways right now
you got a lot of wiggle room with 600
000 in the bank so probably what I would
do is take your 600 and pay off your
current residence
uh which you should have done anyway if
you're listening to me but that's that
part where you said you just did part of
what I teach I remember that part I
didn't drive by it I heard it and
um then then I would save like a crazy
person and I might do this deal in five
years where I've got 500 000 left over
after I buy it now that started if you
had 500 000 left over non-retirement
after you move in there you do a million
dollar house 110 000 incomes is low for
a million dollar house but if you're
paying cash for it for whatever reason
it's okay but you do need some liquidity
and it doesn't need to be freaking 90 of
your net worth that's just that's out of
balance or can you save up some money
and and go
multiple weeks instead of lake house a
year and I mean I don't even mind if you
buy you know if your dreams live on the
water I agree I like living on the water
I've got I've got properties on the
water I like it but um water's amazing
yeah but the uh but but it's not amazing
if it steals your piece instead it gives
you pictures so and then no margin here
no margin it's dangerous that's a
dangerous deal no I wouldn't do it I'm
gonna retract I wouldn't do it because I
don't like the fact there's no wiggle
room what I would do is I pay off my
house today and I'd start saving like a
crazy person and make this a three to a
five year dream
and just keep piling up cash and keep
investing with a paid for house but
you're going to do what you're going to
do because you already don't do some of
the stuff we teach so that's up to you
you get to decide but that's
that's what I would do if I woke up in
your shoes
um I find people don't have margin with
their time they don't have it with their
relationships they don't have it with
work they don't have it with money we
just have a margin free Society now man
well it just it it
um there's friction it greats to get
Frayed Ends yeah and you get frayed at
the ends and it's just um because
everything's pushed to the edge and it
takes what would have normally been a
blessing and and you you know you add
two doses of stress to it and all of a
sudden you don't the thing you were
supposed to be in love with you hate and
when you think of it uh psychologically
our brains were designed to to run at
that level when a lion was chasing us
not to live like that yeah it just
rattles everything to our core you know
it's a big old house with a lion chasing
me around inside you just park the line
in the front yard yeah that's right so
we've already deteriorated the Tiger
King right here Kurt is in Fort
Lauderdale Florida hi Kurt how are you
hey Dave how you doing better than I
deserve man what's up
how you doing um I'm 25 I'm not filled
with my job and I'd like to move out of
my parents house
um potentially looking up North but I
have about 50 000 in Investments and 90
000 in my savings and I'm blessed to
have no debt um should I move with the
current housing market situation and
should I wait and if I should wait
should I move some of that savings money
into investment make some money while
I'm waiting
well um the housing market as you
mentioned is quite hot in terms of
buying a home
uh some areas the rental market is also
closed up and it's very difficult to
find a rental and so rental prices are
going up as fast as real estate prices
are which there should be a correlation
between the two that makes sense
um
so uh uh
you have done a wonderful job saving
money sir well done you save all this
money or somebody give it to you
um I'd say about half maybe a little
less than half is an inheritance to my
uncle or rest is all just me saving uh
my my father and my mother since I was
young I've always told them you know
spend half safe half and I just was
never really a big spender so I saved
more than half of that point and so I've
just been saving uh for I've been
working since I was you know 16 so I've
been sitting for a while now and I'm
just had always been looking forward to
buying a house and I just was feeling
now is the right time but with this
housing market I'm just ugh it's kind of
shot down my house you said you might
move up north what are you going to do
for a living when you move
well I'd say within the same industry
but right now I probably go more into
analytics that's what I like to do right
now I do
um more risk management
um so Kurt you know getting some more
analytical so I'm glad we've identified
this because moving up north I think you
had in mind uh there's some companies or
a company or a specific job and I think
that's the part we want to work on first
is you're not happy in your job and so
you know the good news is you're clear
you know what you want to do you have a
good idea of the analytics is where you
want to go I think I determined that
where's a good place to land there then
I'd make my housing decision based on
that
okay so do you have a good idea of some
companies or do you have something when
you say move north are you just thinking
an area or are you thinking company
that's pulling you North
um I was thinking more just Orlando or
Jacksonville because I have a current
social networks there
um that would you know and finding a job
there's obviously a lot of within my
industry there's a lot in Orlando and
Jacksonville I was looking there just to
kind of get away from where I was where
I've currently been where I've lived all
my life you know sure well that's really
good strategy so Kurt I I think you now
you need to take some action steps and
so I I would begin if you haven't
already you obviously have the social
networks there I would actually begin to
engage those social networks around
those companies you identified both
friends connections and uh several
companies that are in your industry or
at least you know that it's pretty hot
there I'd start making those connections
I'm going to give you a copy of my
number one best-selling book The
Proximity principle which actually walks
you through step by step how to make
those connections who specifically
you're looking at because I think if you
get really serious about that Kurt right
now you're in great shape financially
let's find those opportunities let's go
ahead and get interviews let's land the
gig and I think the housing decision
will take care of itself because you've
been very smart with your money but
let's land a job and then let's make a
housing decision as a part of that yeah
here's what I I will just add to that
let's take that I'll take the back end
of that strategy so start working the
social networks you're only a few hours
from those towns
um get the job landed then go rent an
apartment for six months
then during that six months start
looking for property don't overpay you
there's no reason for you to have house
fever you can take your time and if the
Market's quite hot and you have to
dramatically overpay to get a house then
that's God's saying don't buy a house
right now
just wait Blake is with us Blake is in
Raleigh North Carolina hi Blake how are
you
hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
been waiting on you to say that
um so I have a question
um my wife and I uh have wanted to build
a house and um every Builder that we
speak with uh has quoted us way over
budget
um so uh it seems that prices to build
are continuing to go up and so we have
started to look at existing homes
um but those are also very expensive
um we're currently renting a two-bedroom
single wide trailer and we have two
children
um
so we're just kind of uh we're kind of
stuck we we could
um you know pick a smaller house plan
um but you know right now I don't think
we would want to go much smaller than
what we've already chosen so I'm just
wondering if you think we should wait it
out should we be looking at other homes
um just wanted to get your advice okay
and you're debt free and you have your
emergency fund plus a down payment
yes sir good so you're ready to go well
I would continue to look this is your
first home purchase I take it
uh we actually sold our first home
um in August and uh you know with hopes
to do this and so when we sold we moved
into this rental house so this would be
our second home okay all right well in
general here's a couple things to take
into the formula okay number one uh
generally speaking with rare exceptions
used housing is less expensive than new
new is usually the the Top Line Bar of
how we set values in residential real
estate
all right and so you know you're going
to get more bang for your buck with a
huge house in general and if you're
having trouble making something fits
your budget then that's going to be part
of your answer for sure the second thing
you've got is uh we are in a very very
very unique time right now uh with the
lumber factories being shut down during
covid there became a huge shortage of
lumber and lumber prices have gone up
exponentially in the last little while
and the primary the largest cost item on
your p l or on your project list as
you're building a home is Lumber
and so uh we're even seeing builders in
some areas not agree to lock in the
price like a little bit to your house
for X but if Lumber goes up more we're
going to have an escalation clause in
that contract I'm hearing stuff like
that happening out there okay and so
um which I would not sign up for that by
the way
because steel is doing the same thing I
got a huge price increase on the
building I'm building next door our uh
conference center that we're putting up
that we're breaking ground on next month
we just got the prices in and we've had
a huge increase on the steel Steel's
done exactly the same thing so uh the
these unbelievable High increases in
prices on Lumber and steel are temporary
but will they ever come all the way back
down to where they were I don't know but
it's a simple Supply demand thing that
there was just not any and everybody was
chasing what few was there and so when
the supply dries up and there's high
demand it always drives price up that's
seventh grade economics and so that's
what you're facing on the New Home
Building side it's it's uh one of the
toughest times in
decades to build a new home right now
because of escalating prices on uh on
there all kinds of different things and
there's this huge influx of people back
into the real estate market there's a
shortage of inventory in the real estate
market Across the Nation to give you an
idea February to February February of 19
to February of 20. real estate went up
3.9 percent Nationwide in value
from February of 20 to February of 21 it
went up 14.9 percent
well and so that's that's used housing
but part of that is that riding the cap
of the shortage of inventory and the
shortage of the lumber driving these
lumber prices up so if I'm in your shoes
I'm not going to ride it out now I'm
going to probably go ahead and buy a
used house I'm probably going to park my
plans to build uh until some of the
Smoke Clears on this craziness that's
out there let this Market balance back
out a little bit you'll be able to get
better attention from a builder and
you'll be able to get a a more
predictable reasonable price and that
might be three years but in the meantime
I don't want you in that trailer I'd be
I'd be buying something that'd be my
plan yeah hey thanks for the call it's a
crazy time this stuff is white hot out
there it really is but you know there
are some opportunities you know I was
reading a story recently On The Wall
Street Journal how a lot of young
couples are moving out of urban areas
and into Suburbia and they're buying
older homes that are still a good value
but what they're doing is is they're
taking their cash and they're putting
the cash into Reno so again we speak we
preach cash on this but a renovation
yeah but if you can renovate it and kind
of make it more valuable make it livable
if it's livable to begin with you know
they got two little girls here yeah so
depending on how short he is they had
planned to sell and then buy you know
just keep saving and get pretty close
but I would go the used route too I
agree with that just because you can't
go wrong there yeah yeah well and you're
either way whatever you do you need to
be in the ownership role because it's
going to go up it's right I mean a for a
15 14.9 15 increase in real estate
prices in one year I haven't seen that I
haven't seen that since the 70s yeah
when we had double digit inflation right
and real estate was a big part of that
when I got in the real estate business
in 1978
they taught us when we're doing a
comparative market analysis to an
appraisal that for every month that the
comp was old add one percent for
increase in value so if it was a
four-month-old comp you'd add four
percent that's a 12 annualized wow and
uh of course that's not happened in
decades and do you see it being how much
because I think it's temporary yeah
because we're seeing this because I mean
it's all this simple by demand it was
just this pent-up demand everybody
sitting around looking at their house
going I hate this place yeah and they
hadn't spent that much time at home
before right and so they put on the
market sold it and and there's just a
shortage is it also because New home
builds have slowed down so once they
speed back up now inventory increases
and then pricing drops yep because you
couldn't get Lumber are you worried
about a housing bubble no why no
uh but because there's a shortage of
inventory that'll balance out yeah this
is not um this is natural Supply demand
is what you're saying it's not some
false it's not just a froth it's not a a
hyper crazy people going nuts okay just
for the sake of going nuts
Lisa is with us in Spokane Washington to
start off this hour hey Lisa what's up
hi Dave thanks for taking my call um
so here's the deal my husband and I were
in the process of building a house we
actually had the foundation go in last
fall with construction due to resume the
spring and then we found out last week
that our construction budget went up 40
percent so we've been on this financial
plan to do this really intelligently and
now it's just gone off the rails so
we're gonna put that on hold
um due to covid and I have this big
chunk of money sitting in our savings
account waiting to pay for this home but
now we're going it's not working for us
right it's making what one percent in
our savings account so we'd love to get
your advice to have some thoughts on
whether to just park it in the savings
account we have a rental property that
um
we owe some money on we had sold our
primary home and I'm renting a home
right now
um just could use some Direction
why'd you stop building last fall
so it's we're building on in a mountain
environment up at a ski resort and oh
you have to whether
exactly so we put in there you don't
have your materials and all locked down
by contract
so we
no so we just found out literally last
week he told us he did he gave us a
revised that's the difference in your
sweet people and me I wouldn't be a
little bit let down I'd be pissed off
like 40 pissed off
that was his job to lock this up I mean
my gosh yeah I'm working with a
contractor right now building a building
or anticipating a building we're
breaking ground on in two weeks and I've
been wearing them out about locking in
everything because you can because of
the same stuff you're facing these these
shortages on materials have gone through
the roof caused prices to go through
we're gonna see inflation come back I'm
afraid because of it hi so how long do
you what is your guess on when you
actually do build
do you think that it will go back
oh well yeah I don't know economists and
weather forecasters are the only people
that can be wrong and keep their jobs
doctors predicting Virus Infection rates
but um there he did he went and they
said they can be wrong and we keep their
jobs too but um uh but anyway the uh uh
for me
I am pretty sure you're gonna see
something come back down there's a
reason that steel and wood and lumber
and now plywood right behind it are
going through the roof as I understand
it from the people we're working with in
the business because I've got several
construction projects underway myself
and uh plywood is actually glue there's
a glue shortage and that makes the
plywood with and so we're going to see
plywood probably triple in the next 90
days is what I'm hearing
um and it's already high Lumber packages
are it's the factories were shut down
and they were not producing
uh inventory Supply at the rate even at
the rate that it was going it's not like
there was this huge building Spike and
the factories were operating at normal
they weren't operating at all and then
on top of that there was a good sized
spike in building so as the spike slows
down and the factories get back to
capacity Supply demand curve is going to
drop these prices down steel is not
going to stay where it is uh not not for
not for five years it might for 24
months though I don't know I I don't
know on that but um
so it so the answer to your question is
how long do you think you're parking the
money the longer you're going to park
the money the more you're going to want
to put some of it into something like an
index fund and take a little bit of risk
with it to get a little bit more money
so it could be two to three years okay
so you're thinking I would love it you
emotionally are prepared for a two-year
storm okay I don't know that you're
wrong on that
um so I'm curious Dave how much do you
owe on the rental property
okay so we owe 103 on the property and I
have a hundred and eighty thousand
sitting in their savings account okay
when you get ready to build would you be
willing to sell the rental if you had
paid it off and needed the money
if I need to we definitely would do that
yeah because yeah
I mean I mean that's a really safe place
to get a three or four percent rate of
return on that hundred Grands pay that
mortgage off
okay Ken's got a point that's where he's
going I jumped the gun but yeah that's
what you were thinking how much money's
in the savings for this building project
so I have a 180 and Innings and we
already have you know we own the land
outright and we have no debt on the
foundation and and done so we already
have you know
a hundred thousand okay parked over
there in concrete right now but that's
that's another here or there you're not
going to tear that down so no yeah I I
you know you could either do one of
three things or some mix of them pay off
the home the the rental and then be
willing to sell it when you gear back up
because you're gonna need the cash back
out of it I'm not going to turn on
borrow back on it uh if you do that
that's kind of a point of no return on
that the second thing is you could park
some in an index fund index funds are
going to follow the market whatever it
does uh I mean you could lose 10 of what
you put in there over a two year period
of time it'd be highly unusual the
number of times a two-year period in the
stock market's history is down 10 so
like two percent of the time or
something it almost never happens but it
could I park stuff for short term like
that if I can afford to lose the spread
lose five or ten percent on it uh in an
index fund and you might make ten
percent instead of one percent on that
portion and then some of it you park in
just cash and that's your safety
bellwether
mm-hmm so I probably wouldn't do the
rental and the index fund I'd do one or
the other and leave the other half in
just cash
yeah
okay she got half of it real safe half
of it's either in that rental and into
the OR into the index fund that kind of
thing hey thanks for the call if you
thought this episode was good click here
for the next one where you're going to
hear some of the most epic Dave Ramsey
rants of all time